[Music]
it's like
i'm looking for someone to eat for
dinner and
every other result on google maps is
fish and chips
mobile fishing chips
[Music]
i'll just do two orders of fish and
chips
[Music]
so i'm in iceland and i just found out
that
the uk went to war with iceland several
times
between the 50s and the 70s over one
thing
fish and chips i'm not kidding there
were
three conflicts between the 50s and the
70s
over fish that they use for fish and
chips let's have some fish and chips
fish and chips this is real i want to
tell you the story
buckle up yeah what kind of fish is
called would you like some fish and
chips
it is above all the home of the vital
fishing industry nato's banner flies
yes i know i have done fish wars
in multiple different permutations from
india sri lanka
prawn wars to us canada fish wars
well here's another installment of how
fish make it really hard to draw borders
because they live in the ocean
and so countries fight over them
make it beautiful
to understand why the uk would go to war
with iceland
you have to understand fish and chips
fish and chips are a giant deal in the
uk
it's like i need to get those stats up a
quarter of britain's
eat fish and chips once per week first
thing
i think we ought to take a look at is an
english pub
pubs all around the country serve
millions tens of millions hundreds of
millions
of meals of fish and chips every year it
is
an institution it is a part of the
cultural fabric
however britain doesn't have enough fish
to upkeep this demand for fish and chips
so where do they turn to
iceland so the fish that they use for
fish and chips
is called cod
cod is a delicious buttery creamy fish
but do you know who else loves cod
iceland
in fact you might argue that iceland
loves cod more than any other country on
earth
if you need proof of how much iceland
loves cod
you just gotta go into one of these
grocery stores and you will see it
right on the shelves
[Music]
okay who wants to try some dried aged
cod
so yeah iceland loves cod in fact they
used to have
cod on their coat of arms like it is a
part of their national identity
and to understand why they love cod so
much you just need to look at the oceans
around this island
these waters surrounding iceland here in
the north atlantic are
some of the most well-stocked waters on
earth with
fish especially cod this country
has relied for centuries and continues
to rely
deeply on fish i've been driving
all around this country deep into the
west fjords and
all around every region of this country
everywhere i go i see fish
and fishermen and fishing infrastructure
the lifeblood
of this country of iceland is fish
so you can see where this is going the
british love their fish and chips which
comes from
cod iceland loves their fish generally
especially their cod
and for centuries this hasn't been a
problem iceland has been able to fish
their abundant waters
and britain was also able to come into
these waters and
fish them for themselves but after world
war ii
that started to change
[Music]
oh yeah hello hey there
like uh crack them open put them on a
pan
yup you can do that too
you guys i bought eggs from a bird i
don't really know what
it is but okay why'd you there's wheels
nope we are eating these eggs
we're going to eat these eggs
man it feels so good to be on the road
again
after year and a half home
so good total war patterned by the nazis
for all europe comes at last to germany
you have to understand that after world
war
ii the entire world changed suddenly you
have these superpowers especially the
united states
calling the shots on what a new economic
world order was going to look like and
that came with a lot of trade
suddenly if you had an abundance of some
resource you could ship it somewhere
else and
make money for your country so iceland
started to participate
more and more in the global fish trade
they had
so much fish in their waters outside of
their country
and they were like we should just start
like shipping this abundance to other
people
and making money for our country but
when they started to go out into their
waters
to fish more and more what they saw was
a bunch of
british fishermen out in their waters
who had been fishing there for years
well hello there chaps and the british
were like well
you don't technically have any claim
over this water it's technically
international waters you've never
claimed it so we can fish here
and iceland was like you're right let's
change that
iceland's territorial waters where they
exclusively could fish
only extended four nautical miles off
their coast
not very much the british were like cool
like we don't need to go into your
little four mile zone
so iceland this tiny country was like
we're going to extend it to 12 miles
the british were now technically fishing
inside of
icelandic waters but britain one of the
most powerful countries in the world was
like
cool there's this island nation of a
hundred and seventy thousand people
with no military and they've just
declared that their boundary goes
12 miles into the ocean cool and they
totally ignored it
try and stop me so it's the 1950s
britain is fishing fishing fishing their
fish and ships cod
off the coast of iceland and iceland has
no navy they have no
way of really enforcing this besides
their coast guard
so they send their coast guard out to
detain the fishermen the british
fishermen
and this works for like two seconds
until the british sends in their like
legit navy
to scare off the coast guard and thus
begins
the cod wars i want to say thank you to
today's sponsor which is skillshare
i've used skillshare for many many years
long before they came to
sponsor a youtube video skillshare is a
giant repository of amazing classes and
tutorials on
every subject you can imagine it's a
huge community of
curious people who want to learn
different skills from photoshop to
illustrator to
entrepreneurial skills they even have
classes on
meditation there's one about meditation
for creativity which i'm a big
fan of the cool thing about skillshare
is you pay one monthly price and you get
unlimited access
to all of these tutorials and classes
and courses
skillshare is offering the first
thousand people who click the link in my
description
one month for free of skillshare
unlimited access to all of this material
in one month's time of free skillshare
you could take
dozens of these classes and learn tons
so skillshare is for the creative
entrepreneurial
anyone who wants to learn skillshare is
a fantastic place for you
so click that link in my description
doing so signing up helps support this
channel but it also
gets you a month free of skillshare
thank you skillshare for sponsoring this
[Music]
video
[Music]
so it's now like the 1950s and the
icelandic coast guard
is holding their ground they're showing
up to the ocean whenever they see
british ships
and they're confronting the royal navy
they're not backing down even though
they are a tiny country with no
firepower and no leverage they are not
backing down because they freaking love
cod delicious i'm like dude iceland
punching above your weight here this is
amazing and guess what
it works the royal navy backs down and
britain finally recognizes
this 12 nautical mile boundary that
iceland unilaterally declared for
themselves
the first cod war is over
and now we are entering the west fjords
hold on look at a map
we're in this rv and i'm not really sure
it's gonna handle these gravel roads but
we will quickly find out if it does
handle these gravel roads
i'm just excited to see iceland at some
of its most rugged
here we go
so now we are in cod peace cod peace
lasts for about 10 years but britain is
getting tired
of their expensive cod for their fish
and chips
they want more cod and iceland is the
place to get it so they come back
so british ships are now showing up into
the iceland zone
leaving the waters depleted iceland will
not have this they freaking love their
cod they are not going to let britain
steal it
so they decide to up the ante and they
declare
a 50 nautical mile boundary they're like
all of this water is now
ours back off britain this really pissed
off britain and not just britain but
also
west germany and denmark because now
iceland's
water expansion was now getting into the
waters of these other countries who had
fisheries in this area
but iceland didn't care they're like
listen we love cod
this is like the best fishing in all of
the atlantic we are not backing down
even though we have no army and we only
have 170 000 people
i'm not [ __ ] leaving cue cod wars
number two
[Applause]
in 1972 again without international
legal backing
they increased this to 50 miles the uk
took this one to court first
and international arbitration ruled in
favor of the uk they're like dude
iceland you can't just extend your
waters 50
nautical miles into the ocean you can't
do that and guess what iceland said
yeah they'll just watch me
and they just totally ignored it
so even though the most powerful
countries in the world plus some of
their friends
and an international court ruled against
iceland
iceland dug in their heels and was like
i'm not [ __ ] leaving
britain is getting tired of this they're
like come on guys
we need to fish these waters we need our
fish and chips
like you have no standing here we're
done
so they send in their navy once again
[Music]
the british navy decides to escalate
things a little bit and start
ramming the icelandic coast guard boats
no more warning shots no more soft core
standoffs we are now ramming each other
this leads to a series of standoffs
in the north atlantic between icelandic
coast guard
and the royal navy the most powerful
navy on earth
these fish and chips people they love
their fish and chips
it's really good it's delicious so does
iceland back down in the second cod war
and say okay fine the international
court ruled against us
britain and west germany and denmark
don't like this
we're just gonna chill out no they
didn't they kept it up
and in fact they decided to pull out
their one major piece of leverage in all
of this
which was their alliance with nato
nato land is composed of 14 different
nations
with a combined army seven million
strong
easily my favorite part about iceland is
that you can be driving through some
random mountain pass
like we've been doing at midnight
and you can wander upon waterfall after
waterfall after waterfall that are just
there they're just there just look at
this waterfall that i'm looking at
it is insane
iceland was a member of nato nato was
founded
april 4 1949 by 12
nations of widely different languages
and customs
during its six years nato has well
proved its power for peace and
they occupied a fairly important role
because of where they exist they exist
right here
in the north atlantic a very strategic
place
so iceland decides to pull out their
wild card the thing that they've been
holding onto this whole time which is
we will withdraw from nato if you do not
recognize our 50 nautical mile
boundary of the ocean if iceland
withdraws from nato
because of something the british did the
u.s is going to be pissed
at britain
so britain was like okay fine you win 50
miles you got it gosh darn it i give up
it's yours you can have it cod wars
episode 2
is over iceland wins again
so this is now the second time that
iceland this
tiny country with no military has
like bested one of the most powerful
countries on earth
all because of fish they freaking love
fish here like don't mess with iceland's
fish
but this isn't over it's the 1970s and
we're about to commence
cod war episode 3 return of the cod
[Music]
officially made it to the westernmost
point of europe i think that's right i
mean we
we tried to say we were in the
westernmost point of europe like two
years ago
in this moment just a 30 minute drive
outside of downtown sintra is the
westernmost point of continental europe
and yeah
that obviously wasn't i mean it was like
continental europe
so now we here we are again the
westernmost point of europe right here
[Music]
i don't know where we are but we're
really freaking west we've been driving
for like four hours on dirt roads
to get to this cliff on this very tip of
iceland
in the west fjords and we're here to see
puffins what are we here to see son
i'm popping yes
i'm waiting for you big teen
man these puffins are just right here
they were just right under her nose the
whole time look at this
[Music]
i mean i guess i'd seen puffins like on
the instagram or something but i had no
idea just how
striking these birds are this has
photographing these birds today has been
just it's really helped me appreciate
[Music]
them
[Music]
episode three is basically a repeat of
the last two episodes
the british move into these waters to
get their little fish because they want
fish and chips more ramming tons more
ramming
more standoffs britain is not okay with
this tiny country pushing them around i
mean it's britain they're used to
literally taking over any country they
want in the whole world
and they're being told what to do by
this little tiny island nation they're
not liking it what i love about iceland
is that they don't just dig in their
heels and not concede
they always push a little bit further so
this time they're like we don't just
want 50 nautical miles we want
200 nautical miles off our coast
for exclusive fishing britain is like
no this is not good how are we getting
bested
every time we try to fish this got so
bad that the uk
and iceland actually broke off
diplomatic relations
they were like really angry at each
other until the americans come in and
they're like dude
stop it nato the cold war nuclear
weapons
like stop crying over your fish and
chips we have bigger priorities chill
out
dickwad and so they backed down and they
recognized the 200 nautical mile
claim that iceland was asserting turns
out a couple years later
the un developed the united nations
convention and law of the sea a big
document
that actually codifies that every
country
gets 200 nautical miles of exclusive
economic activity
but iceland was already thinking in
these terms they're like the exclusive
economic zone hipsters like they were
far ahead of everyone else
[Music]
there are always sheep
on the side of the road here including
loads of
baby sheep that are so precious it
always seems like they're about to dart
out in front of the side of the road
giving us loads of anxiety
but they're very cute
[Music]
izzy's never seen reindeer before so
she's taking in the reindeer
[Music]
so what did the cod wars teach us well
as an international relations guy
i'm sort of like this doesn't square up
with a lot of the theories that i
learned in school
in school we learned that when countries
trade with each other
and with when they're bound by alliances
they tend to cooperate
better than ever in this case what you
see
is countries that are bound to each
other through alliance and through trade
who are not cooperating because they are
bound to each other
by trade and institutions in fact one of
the major bargaining chips
in the war was the fact that
iceland was going to withdraw from nato
they used the institution
as leverage we have declared
that icelandic law will be a hell and
i have on that score nothing more to say
all of that is to say this is a super
unique case of a tiny country
using its leverage to basically
make one of the most powerful countries
in the world concede and it totally
worked this is me all right i'm not a
[ __ ] athlete this is my [ __ ] way
this is how i win
but the bigger lesson for me is and the
thing i'm gonna take away is
don't [ __ ] with iceland when it comes to
fish
okay see you later